okay awesome so before I get started I
want to thank Liat and Nikhil for
inviting me and for organizing this
workshop it's been really great so let's
give them a round of applause I'd also
like to thank you for still being here I
know as great as it's been I'm pretty
tired at this point and so I'll do my
best to kind of reward you for sticking
it out until the bitter end so I'm gonna
be talking about affordable housing and
I think affordable housing is something
that probably many of us don't
necessarily have first-hand experience
with so I thought I'd get started by
talking a little bit about what are the
different types of affordable housing so
one thing that we often hear about is
public housing so public housing there's
over a million families living in public
housing in the United States today it's
federally funded so HUD the Department
for Housing and Urban Development is the
one that's actually providing the funds
but they're giving it to all of these
local housing authorities who actually
administer and run the the public
housing units in their city or town now
a lot of you may be surprised to hear
the public housing is still a big deal
in the United States that's because
we're really not building any more of it
but we're maintaining a lot from debt
that was built decades ago so most of
for example the units in New York are
over 30 years old now another federal
program is section eight you may have
heard of section 8 vouchers so this is
actually the biggest component of HUDs
budget and provides housing for 2.4
million families and I'm not going to
talk about it today I have another paper
and I'd be happy to talk to you about
section 8 but that's not going to be the
point today but there's another type of
affordable housing which is increasingly
I guess trendy which is what people call
inclusionary zoning and so the idea here
is that we want to create diverse
neighborhoods with people from different
socioeconomic backgrounds all living in
the same place and we want to do that
without the government spending money
directly and so the way to do that is to
have the government
offer incentives to developers for
example normally there's the zoning
restriction that you can't build more
than 10 storeys but if you offer 20% of
the units you build at below market rate
we'll let you build 14 stories so there
are things like this there are different
ways of doing it so some cities will
actually mandate that you have to have a
certain percentage below market rate or
pay a fine other cities will give you
some sort of tax break but the basic
idea is that it's a public-private
partnership where the developers are
building housing units that are then
going to be offered at below market
rates yeah so the city also has policies
and procedures that the developers need
to follow when filling these units so
usually the way it works is the
developers are in charge of the process
but there's city oversight to make sure
that they're following certain protocols
so this is increasingly popular it's
kind of it's all done locally so
different cities will have their own
rules about how it's done and so today
I'm going to be focusing on kind of
these two types of housing so how is it
actually being allocated today well
pretty much every public housing
authority is using some sort of wait
list and the rules for the wait lists do
vary I'm gonna take some questions or
some answers from an FAQ for Providence
so in Providence you get on a waitlist
can I choose where I live no what
happens if I refuse your offer you go to
the back of the line right so we I like
this because it's very simple and
straightforward it's also fairly
representative of what most housing
authorities in the United States are
doing right so some of them will say
well if I refuse it apart the first
apartment you're okay but once you
refuse the second offer then you go to
the back of the line you know and then
there's variants thereof but this is
like a pretty representative system
okay now inclusionary zoning in the new
units we're building are generally
allocated very differently so here's the
system in New York and they pretty much
all use lotteries of some form here's
what so in New York there were almost
8,000 units built last year all over I
would say all over the cities not
literally everywhere like I don't think
there were any built in Staten Island
but at least covering many of them of
the borough's and so this is what it
looks like if you actually log on so I
mentioned those protocols and procedures
if you want to qualify for these
benefits as a developer you need to list
the unit on the city's housing connect
portal and so here's a list of different
developments and the application
deadlines if you're interested in
applying for the lottery for that
development and so in order to apply you
create a profile this takes only a few
minutes I went and did it and then you
click this this apply button next to
each of the developments that you're
interested in applying for and they have
separate lotteries for each development
now it might not surprise you to find
out that these lotteries are very
oversubscribed right so every time it's
a slow news day some newspaper will
decide to run an article with
inflammatory headlines and big numbers
so this is something that there is
clearly a lot of demand for at least at
the prices at which it's being provided
and a natural question is how should we
be doing this right so in particular why
are we using wait lists for all of our
public housing & lotteries for all of
the inclusionary zoning you know is
there some reason that the kind of
optimal system would be different in
these two cases and can we say which of
these systems is actually better and
second of all of course there's no
reason to think that either of these is
like an optimal system so we can start
thinking about what other alternatives
exist it might be able to improve upon
them yeah yeah
so did you just you just told us you
have to send them below market rate good
so it basically the government will set
numbers you have to have rents that are
say in this band and often it'll
actually offer a menu of options to the
developers like in New York you can
choose to target very low income people
but then you do only need to take say
15% of your units or you could say
target moderately low income people but
then it has to be 20% of the units you
built but it's not just any number
that's below market rate it's kind of
like a specific schedule set by the
government based on percentages of the
median income
okay so this is a question I wanted to
ask is we know how we're doing it but
how should we be doing it and before we
can answer that question we need to know
what are our goals here what are we
trying to achieve with these policies
and it's actually surprisingly difficult
to kind of pin that down in a precise
way but I will tell you the goals that I
have in mind and I'll also show you how
they get kind of incorporated into my
model so in particular one thing I was
able to find was this document from the
UK that talks about its objectives
explicitly and these are two that I
picked out support for those who have
great need and greater choice for people
who are applying and I think these two
are certainly quite widespread as goals
they're not they're far from the only
goals but they're gonna be the goals
that I'm focusing on today in the talk
and so to have a model that allows us to
actually discuss these issues we need a
few features so first of all we need
agents that are different in their level
of need and I'm going to capture that as
an outside option all right so some
people just have a better outside option
than others and the people with the
greatest needs are the ones with the
worst outside options in my model second
people are going to have different
preferences they're gonna care where
they go and they're not gonna all agree
on which place is the best
and then third maybe least surprisingly
to people in this audience I'm going to
treat this information as private
information and I'm going to assume the
agents are acting strategically in
whatever mechanism we set up
any questions on the background of
housing and how it works next slide I'm
going to jump into a model
either got people who are pretty tired
or who are really eager to see a model
you can assume the ladder
I appreciate that interpretation okay so
the model is in discrete time so in
every period we're gonna have some new
things arriving to the market some of
these things are people some of them are
a new development I'm going to have a
continuum model so we have a continuum
of agents a unit mass of new people
arriving and the new development sadly
can't house all of them right so it can
house some mass Miu less than one okay
so in each period we're going to take
the new people that have arrived and add
them to any previous people that are
waiting from earlier periods they
arrived earlier but haven't been matched
yet and we're gonna have some sort of
matching mechanism where we assign them
to today's development this mechanism is
going to ask them for some information
and use that to determine the matching
so a very simple mechanism would be I
could ask you are you interested in
applying for today's house and you say
yes or no and then I have a lottery
among everyone who said yes right so but
we're gonna allow a very general class
of matching mechanisms so some of these
people are going to be matched to
today's development the rest of them are
going to move on and there's one minor
inconvenience here which is that if we
have more people arriving than leaving
in every period the system is just going
to spiral out of control and while that
may be a reasonable description of
what's actually happening happening it's
not actually very convenient
mathematically so we're also going to
assume that some unmatched agents leave
exogenously with some probability one
minus or the exit with probability one
minus delta
here is that this sort of no good
question so Delta is actually fixed and
the same for everyone okay so that's the
way it's gonna work people arrive they
get matched and then most of them
continue on but some of them leave and
we have to talk about utilities so you
asked about outside options so every
agent has an outside option and the way
to interpret this outside option is in
each period where I'm not matched I get
a utility payoff equal to my outside
option on the other hand if I match to a
particular building I have some value
for that building and I'm going to get a
utility payoff equal to that value for
every period that I stay in the building
so this is how I'm capturing these two
features agents differ in their level of
need and they also have different values
because I'm going to assume that these
values are drawn iid cross agents and
time turns out the really important one
is that their idea crossed I'm sorry yep
so they stay forever or there's time for
the system great so I'm gonna have this
same exit probability even once you've
been matched but when you're matched you
stay matched up perfect yeah so I'm
gonna following the way they actually do
things once you've been assigned to a to
an apartment in general you're not
eligible to apply in the system or to
move so there's increasingly some
conversation in cities about huh maybe
we could improve outcomes by letting
people move you know after they've
initially been assigned but the state of
affairs currently is there are families
living in a lot of these places where
maybe when they got it they needed a
3-bedroom apartment because they had
lots of kids all their kids are out of a
house but they still have a three
bedroom apartment that's just really
underutilized so at least for now moving
is not very common and it's not a
feature of the model at all so once your
match that's where you're gonna be is
just a bucket
yeah yeah so periods and apartments are
in one-to-one correspondence because we
have one new apartment in each period
okay and so now we might hope that this
system equilibrates and we won't want to
look for some sort of stationary
equilibrium now i haven't specified the
action set yet because that's going to
depend on which mechanism we're looking
at but the intuition of what how we
model it is if we fix everyone else's
actions then for me as an individual
agent I'm essentially just facing a
Markov decision process let me have some
decisions to make like do I enter
today's lottery or not and then I'm
gonna stochastic aliy get matched or not
and I'm trying to solve my MDP optimally
so we're gonna match each apartment as
soon as it comes online yeah so it turns
out when you take the combination of
assumptions we have so in particular the
iid nature of preferences and the fact
that we have enough like more agents
than there are spaces and the continuum
model so that this the law of large
numbers applies you are always going to
have enough people that want it yeah
the heterogeneity and the values come
from the pier is not the self not not
the supply right you don't have
basically you assume the sulfite the
each period is the same but different no
that's not correct so so the V is
indexed by both I and J where I as the
agent and J is the time period so you I
might like today's development and you
might not for the same development so
you can think of this as being like
neighborhoods you know I like a unit
that's close to where I already live or
where I have friends or family and if
you work in a different part of the city
it's not nearly so appealing to you so
the answer is because it's
mathematically convenient I think the
next follow-up question is okay which of
the results depend on the iid nature and
I'll be happy to tell that to say more
on that like once I've said the results
so feel free to ask that question again
yeah I basically think of it as like the
simplest model that can get started
answering these two questions of all we
matching the right people and we are we
matching them to the right places that's
right that's right so the fact that it's
identically distributed across agents
isn't going to be so important but
independence across agents is important
okay so let's let's take one of the
systems we've talked about that they're
actually using in practice and let's
embed it into this model
let's choose kind of a matching
mechanism so in particular let's take
the Providence wait list I've entered
the system as an individual agent
I've waited around for who knows how
long and eventually I get an offer and
now I have a decision to make should I
accept this offer or not now if the
place is worse than my outside option
it's easy right I just reject it but
otherwise this is not such an easy
decision because it depends on what I
think about how long it'll be until I
next receive an offer as well as how
good that offer will be and so I'm gonna
make some conjecture like I'm gonna have
to wait taou periods before my next
offer and in terms of how good it will
be its drawn iid from this distribution
which I know and I know my own outside
option and so I can kind of combine all
of this information to make some
decision which is going to be an
acceptance threshold if I'm going to
accept it as long as it's good enough
yeah in essence it's like a it's it
serves the role of a discount factor as
well as actually causing you to exit the
system so that doesn't affect Delta
think of Delta as being like how how
likely I am to stay in the system so
with some probability my mom gets sick
and I decide to move back to my home
state and like leave New York and then I
would have left my housing no matter
what but but I think what you're getting
at maybe and tell me if this is not what
you're getting at so a lot of this is
exogenous what's not exogenous is this
number Tao how long I have to wait until
the next offer
remain that if so the units will remain
vacant prophesied every period right
no no so think about it as if I mean if
I say no to the offer they're gonna go
to the next person on the list and sell
it now because we're in a continuum
model my decision isn't really going to
have an impact on how far down the list
we go but but essentially yeah no I mean
all the units will be filled so if I say
no someone else is gonna take it behind
me but certainly among all of these
quantities here most of them are
exogenous mark model primitives accept
this towel right that the amount of time
I have to wait is going to depend on
other people's behavior okay so in
particular because of this feature that
we're talking about where we're going to
go as far down the list as we need to to
fill the unit if a lot of the people
ahead of me are turning down offers then
I'm gonna advance through the waitlist
very quickly and tau will be smaller so
I need to form some sort of rational
expectations about this tau and of
course tau can't just be anything right
so in particular it's not gonna be
feasible for the developer to say I'm
gonna make you an offer every period
because if they did that then too many
people would accept and they would end
up matching more than the supply they
have so it has to be the case that tau
actually clears the market given the
supply that we have
you say so in a waitlist it's going to
be deterministic or nearly so right so
like every ten periods you come to the
top now because of integrality issues it
could be that it'll be sometimes 10
sometimes 11 and that's just because
we're working in the discrete time model
instead of a continuous time model but
you should think of it as being
essentially every deterministic number
of periods I reach the top of the list
again this is what the decision process
looks like for an agent in this wait
list wait around get an offer I have an
acceptance threshold and after the side
is it worth taking this or waiting
another tau periods for another draw
okay how about the independent lotteries
that they're using in New York so the
decision you face here is slightly
different but similar so now I see a
development today I know how much I like
it I have to decide is it worth entering
the lottery there's no cost to entering
the lottery great so so in practice no
and so given that I think well you the
obvious thing you'll say is why not just
enter every lottery great so now of
course if you win a lottery you actually
have to show up for an interview you
have to give over your papers so there
is a cost to that so it's actually not
going to matter for the purposes of our
model whether we think of it as agents
only apply if they would accept or
agents apply everywhere but then when
given the offer only some of them
actually follow through and accept and
that's that's actually going to be a key
feature so so if you want you can think
of it as every agent just says why not
go down that list of units that I see
click apply every time and then when I
get selected for some of them make the
call then and so in that case the Anette
the analogy of this would be I've just
been notified that I've won this lottery
should I take the building or should I
wait to find out
the results of future lotteries
okay and so to answer that question
you're really comparing how goes
matching today to this unit compared to
my continuation value from staying in
and playing more lotteries down the line
and so again you have to think about the
same things right how much do I like
this unit how much would I like future
stuff and in particular how likely am I
to win the lottery future lotteries
right so if I have if I believe that I'm
very likely to in future lotteries of
course I'm going to set a high
acceptance special today whereas if I
think that the probability of winning
future lotteries is almost zero then I'm
going to accept almost anything today
and so again based on this information
I'm going to choose some acceptance
threshold and again P is this endogenous
quantity that needs to clear the market
and this is so this is the formulation
of these two is basically we're looking
for some sort of consistent P and some
sort of consistent towel and the first
result which I would say it surprised me
when I was first thinking about this but
hopefully may not surprise you as much
given given how I presented this is that
actually these two systems turn out to
be equivalent what do I mean by
equivalent well I mean for every agent
there's an identical probability of
matching an identical distribution of
how much you actually like the place
you've matched to conditioned on
matching and if you're also worried
about well how long do they have to wait
in the system the expected time in
system is also the same for every agent
at the joint distribution of these three
things
so for each agent the probability of
match distribution of what you match to
an expected time and system are the same
[Music]
yes so there's there's a couple of
reasons it's a stochastic problem from
the perspective of the agent one is the
exit probability that I'm not sure if
I'm still going to be around the next
time I get an offer the other is my
value so I know my value for today's
unit but I don't know you know when I
get off with something in two years I
don't know how much I'm gonna like it no
so it would be a stable system for any
Delta in general Delta's gonna be
greater than you technically but
everyone in system exits with
probability Delta so eventually once the
system got big enough it would
equilibrate so the number of people
waiting will depend on Delta if Delta is
very large meaning that I stick around
for many periods then the number of
people competing in any given lottery
will also be very large because I'll be
competing with people who arrived five
years ago and are still trying to win a
house but for any Delta it's gonna be
stable any Delta is strictly less than
one the other way so I renege to one of
the houses and then the next
is gonna accept the one ah [ __ ] I'm
really so there's two different units no
I am first in one I get this offer okay
but I'm second in this other one if I
rename the second one then the one
that's next to me is gonna say yes to
his is gonna leave free the house I
really want right okay so I'm gonna I'm
gonna so in the model these lotteries
are done sequentially so I don't know
the outcome of tomorrow's lottery when
I'm deciding whether to accept or reject
today and in practice that's also a
reasonable approximation although we
could go into DT I mean even though
they're all listed at the same time they
all run kind of sequentially I would say
so that we are gonna use some envelope
theorem type stuff for later results in
the paper this is actually kind of
beyond what you could get from a sort of
revenue equivalence theorem because it
turns out for this result to hold it
will continue to hold if I allow a lot
of agent heterogeneity so as long if we
could have different value distributions
we could have different costs of
weighting and I could add all of these
features to the model and it would still
continue to hold so the the real thing
that's kind of driving it is that is
this question that Nikhil asked which is
we could think of this we could think of
the lottery as instead of first I apply
and I've committed to accepting if
chosen we could instead imagine first
they have the lottery among everyone and
then among the winners of the lottery
they're asked to accept or reject and
once you view the lottery this way these
two systems start to sound very similar
right in both I'm an agent I come in
I wait around waiting for an offer at
some point I hope to get an offer if I
do I can either accept it or I can
reject it in which case I'm kind of back
in the original state that I was when I
entered
and so the only difference is with
lotteries each period I'm flipping a
coin with probability P to decide who
gets offered so the time until my next
offer is geometrically distributed
whereas with a waitlist
it's basically deterministic right like
every three years I get another offer
okay so there's a fart I started with
the question of which of these two
systems is better and at least within
the model the answer is they're
equivalent so great question you mean
like there's a unit that everyone agrees
is or most people agree is better then
yeah
so my informal answer is yes
I'm actually working on a Peng and I are
working on a follow-up paper that makes
that point but it requires a somewhat
different model so within this model I
can't answer that question but actually
yes it turns out that this equivalence
will continue to hold
okay so both of these systems are
equivalent I'm gonna argue that they're
also both bad so what do I mean by that
so here's a map of New York we have
Alice and Bob Alice lives and works in
the Bronx
Bob lives and works in Brooklyn they're
both looking for a break on their rent
we happen to have units in both areas
and they're both posted so they apply in
both of these lotteries now we happen to
resolve the lottery for Brooklyn first
and Alice is selected as a winner and
she doesn't know the outcome of this
lottery here so she's gonna accept it
meanwhile this lottery actually selects
Bob as a winner and he's gonna accept it
right and so we'd like to swap but it
just so happens that those aren't the
lotteries that we won right and you can
do the same obviously the same idea for
the waitlist right we had this unit
first Alice was at the top of the
waitlist when this unit became free we
offered it to her she said yes Bob was
right behind her the next unit we
offered him he also said yes because
neither of them wanted to wait four
years to get another offer so this seems
pretty bad so the goal would be can we
do better and with a bunch of matching
people in the room I'm sure you can come
up with some ideas so let's hear some
thoughts about how we might be able to
resolve this inefficiency that you know
that some people have low purchasing
power compared to your other buyers then
in slinking there a peg
actually helps your venue so it looks
like it's the government give a
certificate that you know these people
have lower purchasing power so if it
fully market mechanism is that you
inflate their valuation for you for the
housing and then you find the market
clearing prices so you actually are
increasing the revenue for the builders
you are finding more economical housing
these people and the government's role
is basically to distribute this
information like maybe give it much
$1.00 okay good so I'm hearing a couple
of different thoughts here so one you're
thinking about how can we maybe favor
the people with worse outside options
and so the Builder is getting a fixed
revenue from these units and I'm not
sure that they would agree that it's in
their interest to attract the people
with the worst outside options but my
adoption doesn't charge you a higher
price so we just say that let's say if
you are half as rich as Bill Gates my
adoption will just double your pay so so
so at the very least you could imagine
trying to buy us the rules of the system
in favor of certain people
now that doesn't directly address this
issue that's kind of more getting at the
equity issue of are we targeting the
right people but something else that you
said which was can we use some sort of
pseudo market with virtual currency
certainly seems like a reasonable thing
to do at least if you're a theorist like
I am right so so yeah so virtual
currency is one possible system we could
think about using what else okay so you
could say well maybe this is like an
initial allocation but can we let them
trade yeah so I'm not gonna explicitly
model that although I will actually use
prove some upper bounds against
benchmarks that include that in practice
I think there are some challenges to
that because of the tie the dynamic
nature of the problem that if Alice gets
assigned maybe it will be several more
months until Bob moves here and maybe by
that point there's a lot of friction and
moving Alice back out of the apartment
that she just moved into but I think
there's you know there's value to
considering it and you're trying to
facilitate that like currently not
allowed but we could imagine trying to
allow it
case you get a window once you get to
the top of the priority list I mean the
tile unfortunately is not once you are
at the top you are top once in your life
you get a better help you get I think
you get a maximum of three offers
depending on the counsel and you're
allowed to you have a three month space
of you to find your place so I guess
it's an ideal market thickening
basically to try and avoid the most
egregious forms of this happen okay but
maybe that's not as much as far as you
want to go so it will still leave an
option for this but at least you're
trying to great so so we could take that
we could take that to the extreme right
and say well why why kick you out after
three months or after three offers let's
just let you keep your spot in line it's
very difficult to schedule these
appointments as you said you have to go
and fill out paperwork and see the
appointments and the scheduling of the
of actually getting people to view the
apartments is very hard right yeah so
I've had conversations with housing
authorities in the United States asking
them the same question and they've given
me the same answer which which is nice
at least we have some sort of
consistency across oceans that basically
it's a lot more work for them to process
lots of rejections and it causes delays
in the allocation of the housing now I
think there are ways to surmount both of
those like I think those are not
fundamental concerns with this so in the
model we're gonna assume that these
rejections are cost less and just allow
allow you to turn turn down offers yeah
or something like that essentially that
our trade the position that we place the
better position yeah so I think that's
kind of the the question here and we I
think there's value to considering that
although it would be relatively more
difficult to implement because of the
dynamic nature right so Alice has
already moved into her place and two
months later Bob gets you know a good
lottery draw for this place in the Bronx
place she never goes there she
essentially takes Bob's place in the
waiting list and ball goes directly
there she gives up the place and offers
it to someone in the waiting list for
want settings that gets that person's
position so if we're doing a waitlist
system you could say right so she
obviously doesn't move up because no one
ahead of her wanted it that but she
might not move down that much yeah so
okay so you could consider that and I
would say like this idea that Alex was
proposing was kind of one extreme which
is that you assume that the next person
who wants it is basically right behind
you and so you don't lose any ground
right no I don't have a continuum of iid
values because I have one value as an
individual agent I have one value per
period so my maximum value I'll ever see
in my lifetime is correct correct yes so
there's someone who really likes this
place I agree right
yeah there's someone who really likes
this periods place
well so within each period there's no
point in trading because everyone's
either allocated or not allocated to
saying I'm gonna hold off on delving
into those those definitions for now but
I want what I want to highlight are some
of the ideas that have been raised here
as well as some others so one you could
let people keep their spot after
rejecting an offer right and this is in
fact exactly what they do in Amsterdam
so in Amsterdam you can keep your spot
as long as you want you could say well
the problem is really that people are
applying even for stuff they don't
really want it's maybe just marginally
better than the outside option let's
prevent them from doing that by limiting
the number of places they can apply
Singapore does something kind of like
that if you are someone who is
experienced in like the tiebreaking
literature and school choice you might
say well this is kind of like doing
multiple lotteries you know like
independent tiebreaking and maybe
something like random serial
dictatorship or a common tiebreaker
would be better and then of course you
might also think let's just give
everyone virtual money and result and
let the market clear that way so once
I'm assigned know my value for a given
building is constant in time
so once I'm assigned I know my value for
this place that I've moved into and
that's not going to change yeah
oh yeah we can do a lot better we can do
a lot better okay yeah no we can do
definitely do a lot better so I'm gonna
start with one thing that I think would
be better which is this common lottery
idea so let's talk very briefly about
how we would implement this so in
practice what I'm imagining is when you
join the system you get a lottery number
now we still have all of those listings
like we had before you can still click
apply for whichever ones you're
interested in and we're still going to
go through the list in order of lottery
number it's just that we're gonna the
lottery number is now linked to your
identity rather than a you know drawn a
new for each building and so if you
happen to apply for a building where
your lottery number is better than
everyone else's you're definitely gonna
get it so that's the that's the proposal
yeah in essence I mean yeah I would say
it maps to that in a way which is that
all of the buildings have a common
ranking over over applicants over agents
yeah and so in the model this also
becomes a very simple thing to analyze
because actually in the model with that
all preferences IID buildings are going
to have the same cutoff for kind of how
good you need your lottery number needs
to be to get in and so what that really
means is that at the beginning of your
lifetime you enter in the system we give
you a number it's either good enough to
get matched or it's not if it's good
enough to get matched it's actually good
enough to get matched anywhere and so
you can choose whichever building you
want and you're just solving an optimal
stopping problem like when when should I
accept it
if you were discreet the thresholds
would be changing yeah absolutely so if
I were in a large discreet model the
thresholds wouldn't be changing that
much if I were in a large discreet model
with additional kind of correlation and
preferences then we have a whole
different conversation to have but yeah
in this model in the continuum model
it's very simple which is just that I
either have a good lottery number and
can choose a lot of things or I don't
have a good lottery number and I can't
choose anything and I think that feature
would still hold true right there for
many agents the ones at the very top
would get to choose pretty much whatever
they wanted the ones at the bottom would
get to choose nothing and then in
reality there would be people in the
middle who who kind of faced more
uncertainty or variation okay so given
this it might not surprise you to hear
that okay the people that win this
lottery are gonna have an incentive to
be picky right because they I know I can
get any development I want I'm gonna
wait until one I actually like and so
sure enough it gives higher value per
match for every agent so when if I fix
an agent and I say they got matched how
much do they like their place the answer
is going to be a lot more than they did
before okay now we can also compare it
to some of the other systems we had on
the previous slide it actually turns out
in this baseline model that I've told
you these are all equivalent
so a particular for those of you that
want an artificial currency and are
worried about the skeptics who say we
could never implement that if you
believe this model it would say well one
way to implement that is just to have a
common lottery now it turns out this
finding is not fully robust even within
the model so I haven't presented it in
this version but we do have waiting
costs in our model and once you add
waiting costs we no longer have that all
of these are equivalent so in particular
you know I'd rather be told right away
that I have my choice of everything
versus like in a waitlist I have to wait
four years and then once I finally get
to the top I have my choice of
everything and so once you had waiting
costs what we actually could say is the
common lottery has higher value per
match than any of these other systems
show you a single entry so single entry
lottery is apply to whatever you want
but you can only apply to one thing and
if you lose I'm kicking you out of the
system actually so I'm allowing that so
if you want you can give people currency
in each period and the currency can be a
function of how long you've waited it
just can't be I can't distinguish you
ex-ante so like two people that have
waited the same amount of time i orehu
have behaved in exactly the same way I
have to give the same amount of currency
due but I would actually allow that that
case so yeah so theorem one without
participation cost these are all
equivalent theorem two with
participation costs the common lottery
actually does the best according to this
measure of value per match and then of
course these are just specific other
systems you can actually show that
asymptotically if people are patient if
they're sticking around in the system
for a long time the common lottery is
the best you can do according to this
measure so this seems great you love the
common lottery but there's one more
thing I want to talk about which is we
haven't we haven't actually talked about
who's matching right so I said at the
beginning we want to
to the right people to the right places
the previous slide is saying this common
lottery does a really good job of
matching people to the right places
right because the lucky winners can
choose whatever they want they're gonna
choose something that's really good for
them the concern is it might not be
matching the right people right so in
particular we're choosing the winners
completely randomly so even people with
very little need have a decent chance I
mean have the same chances being
selected as a winner as anyone else so
that seems potentially concerning now
the status quo may not actually be any
better right so if we think about the
status quo if we imagine that everyone's
applying for every lottery in New York
which is maybe a slight exaggeration but
not too far from the truth
it's possible that that actually also
leads to a random allocation of who's
getting matched but under some
conditions about one condition which we
call there are a lot of agents who have
don't really need this too badly then in
that case we can actually show not only
the independent lotteries are doing a
better job of targeting but actually
this is a fundamental result that is
proved using the envelope theorem about
any to allocation mechanisms as it says
under this condition if I have two
systems and one of them is better at
matching the other ones better at
targeting
so the previous like 30 theorem the
common caucus hasn't gotten you after
class
I know among a huge class that includes
like some I don't want to go and do it
but basically among everything yeah that
that can't see you outside option right
so as long as you take the outside
options as private information among
anything yeah but by this theorem it
also tells you that if this condition is
met it's doing really the worst
targeting that you could do so that kind
of leads us stuck what should we do and
I'm pretty much out of time so I'm happy
to continue this conversation afterwards
but the our answer is basically I think
they should still do something like a
common lottery or a waitlist where they
let you keep your spot there's a few
different reasons I could give to
justify this one is under some
conditions this is utilitarian optimal
so basically any additional targeting
benefit you get from changing to another
system is much less than the losses from
matching people to the wrong places
now you can construct examples of
distributions for which it is actually
important to I mean the most important
thing is finding the right people and
matching them but if that's really what
we need to do then I would argue in
practice we have better ways of doing it
then taking away choice and hoping that
will result in a good sorting but it so
in particular one thing that all of
these systems do is they have income
based eligibility criteria or income
based priorities and so if you imagine
the income is correlated with your
outside option by favoring people with
lower incomes I could also target to
those with worse outside options and
then among those people with low incomes
I should just let them actually choose
where they were gonna live
yeah why can't you just give higher
probabilities if you can measure me you
know you just let them draw from someone
exactly that's what so that's exactly
what I'm saying
in the model we can't measure need right
so in the MA all of our results of her
and you can't measure need in reality I
think we can and therefore in reality I
think that doing something like
independent lotteries is a really stupid
way of targeting to the right people we
should just use our measures of need
target to them explicitly and then let
them choose so I've got I think it's
kind of baffling that we're using these
systems that they are both are kind of
our equivalent in our model but be are I
think pretty bad don't really give
people Choice and why do Amsterdam and
Singapore have better systems and I
think the answer is really the law of
large numbers right so in Amsterdam over
40% of the units in the entire city
our social housing in Singapore over 80%
of units are publicly built so you've
got a big constituency of people that
are going to be pissed off of your using
stupid systems like this whereas in the
United States there's no one really to
advocate for change and I'm hoping that
some of us can actually become those
people and so I've been having
conversations with the housing
authorities in New York and in Minnesota
now ongoing and it's slow and I'm
crossing my fingers and hoping something
works so thanks a lot
[Applause]
is that like an outside market for these
flick to people like swap on their own
it's not allowed so yeah if if a
government inspector comes by and some
finds someone whose name is not on the
household application living in the
apartment you can lose the apartment
[Applause]